>> Bret: PETER DOOCY LIVE ON THE
NORTH LAWN, PETER, THANK YOU.
NOW LET'S BRING IN CDC DIRECTOR
DR. ROCHELLE WOLENSKI.
OF DOCTOR, THANKS MUCH FOR
MAKING TIME FOR US TODAY.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Bret: YOU HEARD THOSE TWO
REPORTS AND OBVIOUSLY THERE IS
CONCERN ABOUT THE MESSAGING AND
WHAT'S COME OUT.
I WANT TO PUT UP A COUPLE OF
FULL SCREENS FIRST.
REFERENCED IN THOSE REPORTS.
FIRST IS BREAK THROUGH NUMBERS.
FULLY VACCINATED AMERICANS.
IT'S A REAL CREDIT THAT
164 MILLION PLUS HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED.
OF THOSE WE'RE TOLD FROM YOUR
ORGANIZATION, THAT
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE AT 6200.
THAT'S .0038% OF FULLY
VACCINATED.
AND OF THOSE DEATHS ARE AT 1263,
.00077% FULLY VACCINATED.
SO, BREAK DOWN THESE NUMBERS AND
THE CONCERN ABOUT THE VACCINATED
AND THE CHANGES THAT YOU ARE
MAKING.
>> YEAH, THANK YOU FOR RAISING
THAT.
SO, I'M 164 MILLION PEOPLE FULLY
VACCINATED AND THAT, I THINK, IS
A TRUE SUCCESS.
AND WE STILL HAVE A LOT MORE
WORK TO DO.
I WANT TO BE VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT
THE INTERPRETATION THAT YOU JUST
MADE WITH THOSE 6200 CASES.
THE CDC MONITORS BREAK THROUGH
INFECTIONS IN NUMEROUS WAYS AND
ONE IS THROUGH PASSIVE
REPORTING.
SO THE REPORT YOU HAVE UP THERE
WITH THOSE 6200 CASES IS PASSIVE
REPORTING.
THAT IS WHEN WE RELY ON HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS TO REPORT BREAK THROUGH
INFECTIONS AS THEY COME IN.
WE CAN LEARN A LOT ABOUT THEM.
BUT WHAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT IS
WOEFUL UNDER REPORTING.
WE ACTUALLY DON'T GET ALL THE
REPORTS THAT WE NEED.
SO WHAT WE DO IS WE BOLSTER THAT
WITH COHORT STUDIES.
THESE ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE THAT WE FOLLOW ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, PEOPLE LIKE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS, LIKE HEALTHCARE
WORKERS, LONG-TERM CARE FACILITY
MEMBERS, AND RESIDENTS.
AND SO WE FOLLOW THOSE TO ASSESS
THE REAL EPIDEMIOLOGIC JIK WAY
TO DO BREAK THROUGH INFECTION
ANALYSIS.
THE PASSIVE REPORT SOMETHING NOT
THE BEST WAY TO DO IT.
>> Bret: UNDERSTOOD THAT I SAW
SOME OF THE STUFF THAT YOU PUT
OUT ABOUT MASSACHUSETTS AND WHAT
YOU LOOKED AT IN THAT ONE
COMMUNITY.
BUT, IN THE INTERNAL SLIDES FROM
THE CDC THAT GOT TO THE "THE
WASHINGTON POST," IT APPEARS TO
SOME OF YOUR DECISION WAS PARTLY
BASED ON A NON-PEER REVIEWED
STUDY FROM INDIA THAT LOOKED AT
VACCINES NOT APPROVED IN THE
U.S.
I GUESS THE QUESTION WHY ARE YOU
USING FOREIGN DATA OF NON-U.S.
VACCINES AS AT LEAST A PART OF
THE BASIS FOR YOUR DECISIONS
HERE?
>> YEAH.
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR.
THAT WAS AN INTERNAL BRIEFING TO
ME TO GIVE THE COMPREHENSIVE
VIEW OF WHAT WAS OUT THERE IN
THE LITERATURE.
THE END I CAN'T DATA WERE NOT AT
ALL USED TO MAKE THIS
ASSESSMENT.
LAST FRIDAY THE DATA FROM MASS
INCLUDES THAT WERE PUBLISHED
TODAY I CERTAINLY DIDN'T WANT TO
USE ONE SINGLE SITE IN ORDER TO
MAKE THAT ASSESSMENT AND TO
CHANGE THESE GUIDANCES.
WHAT WE DID IS LOOKED AT OTHER
SITES THAT WERE THE DELTA
VARIANT VARIANT WHAT WE COULD
GLEAN.
THE DATA WE SAW IN MASSACHUSETTS
WERE CORROBORATED IN NUMEROUS
OTHER PLACES AND THAT'S WHEN WE
KNEW WE HAD TO TAKE ACTION.
BUT, TO BE VERY CLEAR, THAT
INTERNAL BRIEFING WAS NOT THE
DATA THAT WE USED TO MAKE THE
DECISION.
IN FACT, THE DECISION WAS MADE
AFTER THAT BRIEFING.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT.
BUT YOU ARE LEADING WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT THE VACCINES
WORK.
THAT THEY'RE EFFECTIVE, THAT
THEY PREVENT FOR THE LARGE PART
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND THAT REMAINS, FORTUNATELY,
TO BE TRUE WITH THE DELTA
VARIANT.
>> Bret: SO FOR THE MASKS TO BE
ADDED TO THAT, ARE THE
VACCINATED PEOPLE WEARING THE
MASKS TO PROTECT THE
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE OR ARE THEY
PRESKTING THE VACCINATED PEOPLE?
>> THE VACCINATED PEOPLE -- SO
IF YOU ARE VACCINATED, WHEN YOU
ARE VACCINATED, YOU ARE
PROTECTED FROM SEVERE DISEASE
AND DEATH.
WHEN WE REMOVED THE MASKS IN MAY
FOR THE VACCINATED PEOPLE THE
ALPHA VARIANT WAS THE
PREDOMINANT VARIANT.
WE HAD DATA TO SUGGEST AT THE
TIME IF YOU WERE INFECTED AS A
BREAK THROUGH CASE THAT YOU
COULDN'T GIVE DISEASE ALPHA
DISEASE TO SOMEONE ELSE.
FAST FORWARD NOW THE END OF
JULY, THE PREDOMINANT STRAIN
HERE IS DELTA.
SO WHAT -- THE DATA THAT WE SAW
WAS ACTUALLY UNLIKE ALPHA.
DELTA ALLOWS YOU TO TRANSMIT TO
SOMEBODY ELSE.
SO, THE MASKS ARE REALLY BEING
PUT ON FOR VACCINATED PEOPLE IN
AREAS OF HIGH DENSITY DISEASE
SUCH THAT IF THEY WERE TO GET
INFECTED, THAT THEY KNEW THAT
THEY MIGHT BRING IT TO SOMEBODY
WHO IS IMMUNOCOMPROMISED,
SOMEBODY WHO IS NOT YET
VACCINATED.
REALLY TO PREVENT TRANSMISSION.
>> Bret: RIGHT.
DR. WOLENSKI YOU CAN IMAGINE
PEOPLE CONFUSED BY THE MESSAGING
FROM THE BEGINNING TO NOW.
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING VARIANT CAUSED REVOLUTION
OF WHAT HAPPENED.
GOOD EVENING.
THIS IS DOMINIC FROM VIRGINIA
WITH A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
IF IT'S CONSIDERED RARE TO GET
COVID-19, IF YOU ARE FULLY
VACCINATED WITH THE DELTA
VARIANT, WHEN WILL WE EVER GET
BACK TO NORMAL WHEN MASKS ARE
NOT REQUIRED?
AND MY SECOND QUESTION IS IF
OTHER VARIANTS COME ALONG AT
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF CASES OF
HOSPITALIZATIONS DO YOU NOT
RECOMMEND WEARING MASKS?
THANK YOU.
>> Bret: LET ME PUT A FINER
POINT ON IT WE STARTED THIS
WHOLE THING WITH TRYING TO STOP
THE SPREAD AND WE WERE GOING TO
FLATTEN THE CURVE TO PREVENT
HOSPITALS FROM BEING OVERRUN.
BUT NOW IT DOES SEEM,
DR. WALENSKY, TO DOMINIC'S POINT
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO KILL THIS
VIRUS ENTIRELY AND CAN YOU JUST
ANSWER HIS PERCENTAGE POINT
QUESTION.
>> THANK YOU DOMINIC, FOR THAT
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT AS WE THINK ABOUT
THE ABSOLUTE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE GETTING INFECTED, THAT
IS RELATED TO THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DISEASE.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
VACCINATED AND HOW WELL THOSE
VACCINES WORK.
SO IT IS ACTUALLY QUANTITATIVELY
POSSIBLE TO HAVE 95% PROTECTION
FROM HOSPITALIZATIONS AND STILL
HAVE A LOT OF BARACK THROUGH
INFECTIONS IF MOST OF YOUR
POPULATION IS VACCINATED.
>> Bret: BUT IS THERE A
NORMALCY?
IS THE NEXT VARIANT AROUND THE
CORNER AND THAT IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE ALWAYS
GOING TO BE ON THIS STOP AND
START WITH PUTTING MASKS ON OR
NOT?
>> SO, I WANT TO JUST ARTICULATE
THAT THIS WAS NOT NEWS THAT I
EXPECTED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
WELCOME.
THIS WEIGHED HEAVILY ON ME TO
HAVE TO DO THIS.
BUT I WILL ALSO SAY THAT THIS
VIRUS HAS BEEN HUMBLING.
I WAS TAKING CARE OF PATIENTS A
YEAR AGO.
I JOINED THE CDC SIX MONTHS AGO.
AND THE SCIENCE CONTINUES TO
CHANGE.
AND WHILE THAT IS NEITHER SIMPLE
NOR EASY TO CONVEY.
IT'S MY RESPONSIBILITY TO KEEP
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SAFE.
AND AS THAT SCIENCE EVOLVES, I
EVOLVE -- WITH THE CDC, OF THE
GUIDANCE, WHAT I WILL SAY IS I
CONTINUE TO BE HUMBLED BY THIS
VIRUS.
I HAVE NO INTEREST IN CONTINUING
MASK GUIDANCE.
AND THE BEST WAY TO STOP A NEW
VARIANT FROM SPREADING IS TO
HAVE LESS VIRUS OUT THERE AND
THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IS TO
GET PEOPLE VACCINATED AND TO
MASK UP UNTIL THEY ARE.
>> Bret: DR. WALENSKY, YOU SAID
THE OTHER DAY THAT WE ARE JUST
TWO OR THREE MUTATIONS AWAY FROM
A VARIANT THAT CAN'T BE DEFEATED
BY OUR VACCINES.
THERE WERE SOME FORMAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS, TOP HEALTH OFFICIALS
WHO FOUND THAT TROUBLING AND
THOUGHT IT WAS A LITTLE BIT OF
FEAR-MONGERING BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE THAT THE VACCINE THAT WE
HAVE CURRENTLY, THE MRNA CAN BE
ADJUSTED TO DEAL WITH WHATEVER
VARIANT COMES DOWN THE LINE AND
CAN BE FIXED WITHIN A MATTER OF
TIME AND SHORT MATTER OF TIME.
IS THAT FACTUAL?
>> UM, I THINK BOTH ARE
POTENTIALLY TRUE.
I SAID I BELIEVE A FEW MUTATIONS
AWAY.
YOU KNOW, THE VIRUS IS SMART.
THE VIRUS IS OUT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT CAN SURVIVE AND IT AN
OPPORTUNIST TO GO WHERE WE ARE
NOT VACCINATED.
THE MORE THE VIRUS IS MUTATING.
THE MORE IT HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MUTATE AWAY FROM OUR VACCINES
AND TO BE ABLE TO EVADE THEM.
THAT, I THINK, IS TRUE AND
THAT'S THE GENERAL CONCERN OF
SCIENCE.
WE'RE NOT THERE YET AND WE ARE
VERY LUCKY TO NOT BE THERE YET.
WE HAVE A LOT OF VIRUS
CIRCULATING HERE.
IT IS VERY TRUE AND I THINK IT'S
SCIENTIFIC WIN THAT WE HAVE MRNA
VACCINES THAT CAN BE ADAPTED FOR
NEW VIRAL VARIANTS, NEW
MUTATIONS AND THAT'S AMAZING.
HOWEVER, THAT WILL TAKE SOME
TIME AND SO WHAT WE WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO DO IS NOT HAVE TO BE IN
THAT PLACE.
>> Bret: LAST QUESTION QUICKLY
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A BREAK IN
A SECOND.
SPEAKING OF TIME, WHEN IS THE
FDA GOING TO AUTHORIZE THE FULL
APPROVAL OF VACCINES THAT HAVE
BEEN ON EMERGENCY AUTHORIZATION
SO FAR?
THE PRESIDENT THE OTHER DAY SAID
IT'S THE FALL, BUT THE FDA HAS
PUT OUT THAT IT MIGHT BE JANUAR.
WHY IS IT TAKING SO LONG?
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW THE
FDA'S TIMELINE OR PLANS.
I WILL LEAVE THAT SQUARELY WITH
THE FDA.
WHAT I DO KNOW IS THAT THE DUE
DILIGENCE ON THE SCIENCE AND
REVIEW AND THE ENDEEM LOGIC DATA
NEED TO R
DR. ROCHELLE WALENSKY.
I WANT TO START THERE.
ARE YOU FOR MANDATING A VACCINE
ON A FEDERAL LEVEL?
>> UM, YOU KNOW, THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION IS LOOKING INTO.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE
ARE LOOKING SEE APPROVAL OF FROM
THE VACCINE.
OVERALL, I THINK IN GENERAL, I
AM ALL FOR MORE VACCINATION.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I HAVE NOTHING
FURTHER TO SAY ON THAT EXCEPT
THAT WE ARE LOOKING INTO THOSE
POLICIES.
AND, QUITE HONESTLY, IF PEOPLE
ARE DOING THAT LOCALLY, THOSE
ARE INDIVIDUAL LOCAL DECISIONS
AS WELL.
>> Bret: RIGHT.
BUT YOU ARE IN THE MEDICAL FIELD
AND YOU CAN HEAR THE PUSHBACK
FROM PEOPLE WHO SAY I NEED TO
DETERMINE WHAT IS PUT INSIDE MY
BODY WITH MY DOCTOR.
SO YOU GET THAT PUSHBACK?
>> I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THE
PUSHBACK AND I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS NOT UNLIKE OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE MANDATED.
OTHER VACCINES THAT ARE MANDATED
FOR SCHOOL GOING CHILDREN.
FOR HEALTHCARE PERSONNEL.
MANDATED EVERY YEAR AS I WORK IN
A HOSPITAL TO GET A FLU VACCINE.
I UNDERSTAND BOTH PERSPECTIVES
IN THAT STORY.
I UNDERSTAND.
>> Bret: BUT WHY IS IT THEN
DR. WALENSKY THAT SUCH A HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF MEDICAL PERSONNEL
ARE NOT TAKING THE VACCINE?
>> UM, YEAH, YOU KNOW, AGAIN,
THIS IS A VERY HETERO GENIUS
COUNTRY.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT CERTAIN PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY, THERE ARE HIGH
LEVELS OF VACCINATION AND IF YOU
LOOK AT OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY THERE ARE LOWER LEVELS
OF THE VACCINATION.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT EVERYONE HAS A
DIFFERENT REASON FOR EITHER
WANTING THE VACCINE OR NOT
WANTING THE VACCINE.
SO THIS IS NOT ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
WHY IS THIS DEMOGRAPHIC NOT
GETTING IT.
SOME PEOPLE HAVEN'T HAD ACCESS.
SOME PEOPLE HAVEN'T HAD TIME
OFF.
SOME PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND ITS
BENEFITS.
SOME PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ABOUT
THE SIDE EFFECTS.
SOLVE THINK AS WE GO AND TRY AND
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT YET VACCINATED, I
FEEL LIKE IT'S OUR JOB TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR
HESITANCIES ARE AND THEN TO USE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE THAT
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN TO TRY
AND USE THAT INFORMATION SO THAT
AT THE END OF THE DISCUSSION
THEY WILL WANT THE VACCINE.
>> Bret: I HAVE TALKED TO A LOT
OF MEDICAL EXPERTS AND PEOPLE I
TRUST THAT THE PROFILE FOR THESE
VACCINES IS REALLY GREAT AS FAR
AS EFFICACY STANDPOINT.
S HOWEVER, THERE ARE INDICATIONS
OF POCKETS AND WHETHER THAT'S
HUNDREDS OR THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE PROBLEMS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO SAY THEY
HAVE LINKED IT TO DEATHS.
WHETHER THIS NUMBER IS VERY
SMALL.
ARE THOSE THINGS BEING LOOKED AT
BY THE CDC?
IS THAT INVESTIGATION HAPPENING?
WE DON'T HEAR ABOUT IT,
OBVIOUSLY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE ARE WATCHING THIS INCREDIBLY
CAREFULLY THROUGH NUMEROUS
DIFFERENT SAFETY SYSTEMS.
THE ADVERSE EVENT SYSTEM.
WE HAVE A SYSTEM OF PASSIVE
REPORTING SYSTEM.
WE HAVE WHAT WE CALL VACCINE
SAFETY DATA LINK THAT IS
CLASHING WITH HOSPITALS.
WE ARE WATCHING THIS
EXTRAORDINARILY CAREFULLY.
AND WHAT I WOULD SAY IS WE HAVE
VACCINATED 164 MILLION
AMERICANS.
SO WE HAVE AN EXTRAORDINARY
AMOUNT OF DATA SINCE DECEMBER AS
WE STARTED GETTING VACCINATING
PEOPLE.
AND WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FIND
VERY, VERY RARE SIGNALS WHEN
THEY HAVE OCCURRED AND SO I HAVE
EXTRAORDINARY CONFIDENCE IN THE
SAFETY OF THESE VACCINES.
>> Bret: YEAH.
WHICH MAKES THE QUESTION ABOUT
THE FDA AND AUTHORIZATION SEEM
REALLY IMPORTANT.
IF IT'S ABOUT SHELF LIFE IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S A LITTLE TOO
LONG.
I WANT TO TURN TO SCHOOLS.
A LOT OF PARENTS SENDING IN
QUESTIONS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE WONDERING WHAT IT'S
GOING TO LOOK LIKE FOR THEIR
KIDS.
ESPECIALLY MASKS FOR YOUNG KIDS
2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
HERE IS JOSH.
>> WHY IS THE CDC NOT LOOKING AT
THE EMOTIONAL IMPACTS AND OTHER
PHYSICAL IMPACTS THAT HAVING A
MASK ON A CHILD AS YOUNG AS 3 OR
4 OR 5, 6, 7 YEARS OLD, NOBODY
SEEMS TO BE TALKING ABOUT THE
EMOTIONAL OR PHYSICAL IMPACTS
THAT HAVING A MASK ON A CHILD
FOR THAT LONG IS HAVING AND THE
CDC SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THIS.
WHY ARE THEY NOT?
>> Bret: ARE YOU NOT OR ARE YOU?
>> BRET, THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION.
JOSH, THANK YOU FOR THAT
HERE'S WHAT I CAN TELL YOU.
FIRST OF ALL, I HAVE THREE KIDS
MYSELF AND I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND.
WE WANT OUR KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL
AND THAT IS SO VERY IMPORTANT.
OVER THE SUMMER, WE HAVE HAD
NUMEROUS SUMMER SCHOOL OUTBREAKS
THAT HAVE OCCURRED WHEN MASKS
ARE NOT WORN.
WE HAVE HAD JURISDICTIONS HAVE
HAD TO CLOSE SCHOOLS BECAUSE
THEY THERE ARE SO MANY CLUSTERS
HAPPENING IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
SO MY PRIMARY GOAL IS TO GET ALL
OUR KIDS BACK IN PERSON SAFELY
FOR FULL-TIME LEARNING AND TO DO
SO AND TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THE
SCHOOLS OPEN TO PREVENT THOSE
CLUSTERS FROM HAPPENING IN
SCHOOL.
RIGHT NOW THE BEST WAY TO DO
THAT IS TO HAVE EVERYBODY MASKED
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE DISEASE IN
THE COMMUNITY.
AND HOPEFULLY AS WE HAVE
VACCINATIONS FOR KIDS, AND LESS
DISEASE IN THE COMMUNITY, WE
WILL BE ABLE TO SCALE BACK ON
THE MASK-WEARING.
>> Bret: THOSE ARE CASE, RIGHT?
THOSE AREN'T HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND THOSE AREN'T DEATHS.
DO YOU HAVE A PERCENTAGE OF
KIDS, YOUNG KIDS
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS?
>> UM, YOU KNOW, WE ARE
FOLLOWING THAT VERY CAREFULLY.
WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT,
CERTAINLY THE KIDS DO BETTER
THAN ADULTS DO.
THE OLDER PEOPLE, THE MORE
HOSPITALIZATIONS HAVE OCCURRED
IN DEMOGRAPHICS THAT ARE OVER
THE AGE OF 65.
BUT, WE ARE SEEING ILLNESS IN
SOME KIDS WHO GET, WHO GET
COVID.
AND IT'S ILLNESS AT THE RATES OR
EVEN HIGHER THAN THE RATES OF
INFLUENZA.
IN MY MIND AS A VACCINE
PREVENTABLE DISEASE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR KIDS STAY IN
SCHOOL, WEARING A MASK.
AFTERNOON THEN WHEN THE
VACCINE -- SHOULD THE VACCINES
BECOME AVAILABLE FOR OUR
CHILDREN TO VACCINATE THEM TO
KEEP THEM SAFE AND HEALTHY.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT.
HERE'S WHAT THE HEAD OF THE
TEACHER'S UNION SAID ABOUT
OPENING SCHOOLS IN THE FALL.
>> VACCINATION IS THE NUMBER ONE
GOLD STANDARD, THAT WE NEED TO,
YOU KNOW, BRING BACK OUR MASKS
FOR SCHOOLS.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP KIDS SAFE,
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP OUR MEMBERS
SAFE, AND WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
OPEN UP SCHOOLS.
>> Bret: TRY TO OPEN UP SCHOOLS
IT SOUNDS LIKE A MAYBE FROM
RANDI WEINGARTEN.
THE NDA IS UNION ADVOCATING FOR
MEMBERS.
AND IMPORTANT STOCKHOLDER FOR
THE CDC OBVIOUSLY SETTING
GUIDELINES FOR SCHOOLS IN THE
FALL.
WHO ARE THE ADVOCATES FOR THE
CHIRP AND THE PARENTS WHICH
TEACHERS UNIONS HAVE NOT BEEN,
AT LEAST IN THAT PARTICULAR
QUESTION AND AS A CDC PREPARES
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IN PERSON
LEARNING, ESPECIALLY FOR KIDS
UNDER 12, AS YOU HEARD JOSH TALK
ABOUT, WHAT'S THE SCIENTIFIC
BASIS FOR MASKING YOUNG
CHILDREN?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT WE
HAVE TO -- WHEN WE HAVE SEEN IN
SCHOOLS THAT WHEN THE CHILDREN
COME IN TO SCHOOLS WITH DISEASE
IN THE COMMUNITY, IT CAN SPREAD
IN SCHOOLS IF THE CHILDREN ARE
NOT MASKED.
AND SO, WHEN WE HAVE HIGH RATES
OF DISEASE IN THE COMMUNITY, WE
ARE GOING TO SEE SOME CASES IN
THE SCHOOLS.
>> Bret: BUT IT'S NOT FOR THE
TEACHERS IN THOSE SCHOOLS?
>> UM, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF THESE
KIDS -- FIRST OF ALL, THERE IS
SOME DISEASE IN KIDS.
THESE KIDS GO BACK TO HOMES
WHERE THEY HAVE PARENTS.
THEY HAVE IMMUNOCOMPROMISED
PARENTS.
THEY HAVE OTHER CHILDREN IN THE
HOUSEHOLD.
SO REALLY WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
DO IS PREVENT SPREAD IN THE
SCHOOLS AND IN THE COMMUNITIES.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, GENERALLY,
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS GET
OUR KIDS BACK IN FULL --
FULL-TIME IN-PERSON LEARNING.
AND TO DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF
DISEASE IN THE COMMUNITIES SO
THAT OUR CHILDREN CAN BE BACK IN
SCHOOL.
>> Bret: LAST THICK.
YOU KNOW, I HEAR FROM A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT SAY, YOU KNOW, THERE
IS ONE THING AND THEN ANOTHER
THING AND WE HEAR IT ABOUT
VACCINATIONS AND MASKS.
WE ALSO HEAR IT ABOUT, FOR
EXAMPLE, ONE WOMAN WROTE IN:  MY
IN-LAWS LIVE IN AUSTRIA, THEY
CANNOT COME HERE TO SEE THEIR
6-MONTH-OLD BABY BECAUSE OF THE
EU TRAVEL BAND EVEN AS MIGRANTS
COME ACROSS THE SOUTHERN BORDER
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES WITH MORE
COVID AND WORSE VACCINE
PERFORMANCE AND THEY ARE ALLOWED
IN.
IS THAT A PROBLEM, DR. WALENSKY?
>> WE'RE WORKING, UM, AT THE CDC
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR ALL AREAS OF TRAVEL AS WELL
AS TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER SO AS PEOPLE COME IN WE
ARE KEEPING MIGRANTS, AS WELL AS
THOSE COMMUNITIES AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE WITH THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND INFECTION
PREVENTION GUIDELINES FROM THE
CDC.
>> Bret: BUT DO YOU KNOW THE
SURGE, HOW THE SURGE OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WITH COVID IS
AFFECTING THE OVERALL RATE, YOU
KNOW, IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
PERCENTAGES DOWN THERE ON THE
BORDER ARE ASTRONOMICAL?
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, I WOULD SAY
THAT THE PERCENTAGES IN THE
SOUTHERN PART OF THIS COUNTRY
ARE REALLY QUITE HIGH AND I
DON'T NECESSARILY THINK WE CAN
ATTRIBUTE ALL OF THAT TO WHAT'S
GOING ON AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
I THINK WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO
DO IS SPEND OUR TIME GETTING OUR
COMMUNITIES VACCINATED TO
GETTING OUR INDIVIDUALS
VACCINATED TO PREVENT DISEASE
FROM TRANSMITTING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
>> Bret: LIGHTNING ROUND HERE.
WHICH VACCINE IS BEST AGAINST
THE DELTA VARIANT?
>> I DON'T THINK WE HAVE DATA TO
SUGGEST THAT ONE VACCINE IS
BETTER THAN ANOTHER?
SO I WOULD SAY, UM, THERE, YOU
KNOW, THREE VACCINES WE'RE LUCKY
TO HAVE THREE VACCINES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AND, GET THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU NEED TO
FEEL COMFORTABLE, ROLLING UP
YOUR SLEEVES AND GETTING
VACCINATED.
>> Bret: YOU ARE GOING TO TALK
TO YOUR DOCTOR ABOUT THAT IF
THERE IS A MANDATE YOU ARE NOT
PICKING ONE OVER ANOTHER AS FAR
AS THE DELTA VARIANT.
IF YOU GOT THE J AND J, IS IT
OKAY TO GET THE PFIZER AFTER
THAT BECAUSE YOU WANT TO?
>> RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE FULL
DATA FROM J AND J OR THE FDA TO
MAKE AN EVALUATION ON THAT
ASSESSMENT.
>> Bret: LEADS TO THAT QUESTION
ABOUT DATA AND DETAILS.
I MEAN, IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME
AND YOU HAVE A LOT OF
170 MILLION PEOPLE THAT OR 64,
DON'T YOU GUYS HAVE A LOT OF
DATA AS OF THIS POINT?
>> SO, THE FDA IS LOOKING AT THE
DATA FROM THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
CONDUCTING THESE ANALYSIS CEASE.
THE CDC IS NOT CONDUCTING
CROSSOVER STUDIES AS WE CALL
THEM GETTING ONE VACCINE AND
THEN GETTING A BOOSTER ON THE
SECOND.
THE FDA HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE
DATA AS THEY MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS I'M SURE THAT DATA
WILL BE PUBLISHED.
>> Bret: SHOULD WE AVOID BIG
CROWDS ARE WE GOING TO HAVE AN
NHL, NBA, NFL SEASON?
>> I'M REALLY HOPEFUL THAT WE
WILL.
YOU KNOW, WHAT I THINK IS REALLY
CLEAR IS THAT IF WE UNIFY
TOGETHER AS A COUNTRY, IF WE
TAKE THE STEPS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO SQUASH THE AMOUNT
OF DISEASE THAT IS THERE NOW, WE
CAN DO SO IN A MATTER OF WEEKS
IF WE ALL GET VACCINATED, IF WE
WEAR MASKS UNTIL THEN, THERE IS
SO MUCH THAT CAN BE DONE IN SUCH
A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME TO SQUASH
THIS AND I WOULD REALLY LOVE TO
SEE KICKOFF SEASON.
>> Bret: LAST THING, ISRAEL IS
ALREADY DOING A BOOSTER FOR
PEOPLE OVER 60.
ARE WE GOING TO DO THAT?
>> WE ARE WORKING AND LOOKING AT
THE DATA AS I MENTIONED.
WE HE HAVE NUMEROUS COHORTS
FOLLOWING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THOSE DATA
EVERY WEEK, EVERY TWO WEEKS.
WE ARE COLLABORATING WITH
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS SUCH AS
ISRAEL AND THE U.K. AND MANY
OTHERS TO LOOK AT THOSE DATA AND
ONE THING I WILL SAY IS THAT
WHEN THE DATA DEMONSTRATE THAT
WE ARE READY TO GIVE BOOSTERS,
THE GOVERNMENT WILL BE READY WE
ARE PLANNING RIGHT NOW.
>> Bret: DR. WALENSKY, WE
APPRECIATE YOU GIVING US
EXTENDED AMOUNT OF TIME AS CAN
YOU HEAR BY ALL THE QUESTIONS
AROUND THE COUNTRY, THERE IS
SOME CONFUSION AND A LOT OF
CONCERN BUT WE HOPE THAT YOU CAN
COME BACK SOME TIME AND CONTINUE
TO FILL US IN.